[Music]
as soon as I got on campus I said to one
of my my travelling companions here is
to make sure that I got a hat and sure
enough there was one in the green room
in the back so it's lovely to be here
and thank you all very much
course well I want to thank you for
joining us tonight chef Keller it's
really an honor to have you on campus
thank you
and I think that's probably safe to say
that you have a very welcoming audience
everyone here has either dined in one of
your restaurants fantasized about dining
in one of your restaurants or heard
their significant other fantasized about
dining in one of your restaurants and
it's actually quite fitting for me
because my fiancee Ben is in the
audience and he has heard me fantasize
about dining at the French Laundry for
years then where's Ben okay I thought
you just got you're travelling aren't
you or is there dessert I'm hoping that
this helps build my case for actually
getting to the French Laundry one day
good I hope so too great weekend
so it all started with dishwashing your
first exposure to restaurants was
washing dishes in one of your mom's
restaurants can you talk about how that
first sparked your interest in cooking
and then also what later drove you to
connect your life's work to cooking well
it's interesting because as a youngster
my mother ran restaurants so being the
youngest of five boys I find my I found
myself in the restaurant after school
doing odd things and certainly at a
young age you know you weren't allowed
to hold a knife or be anywhere near the
fire so the most obvious and safe place
to put me was in front of a dishwashing
machine where you know looking back at
that time I really learned so many
skills that benefited me and becoming a
really really good cook and just to
explain a few of those when you think
about it you know being a dish dish
machine you have to be you have to be
organized you know so setting out all
these sample plates on the dirty dish
drain board so that as the waiters came
back they put the dishes in the right
spots they put the glasses in the right
spot the silver in the right spot you
had to be efficient in the way you stack
the plates and wash the dishes and got
the
the glass is done and putting them in
the racks correctly so that when you put
them in the machine the machine would
wash them and of course by that forty
five seconds later you knew through the
feedback whether the the job that you
had done was going to be satisfactory in
other words the dishes we there came out
clean or they came out dirty so if they
came out dirty you know you didn't do
your job correctly so the feedback was
very important and then the idea that
you really had to be part of a team you
know as a dishwasher most of us you know
think think of that as a really lowly
position but everybody in the entire
restaurant relies on you you have to
give the dishes back to the cooks they
need their dishes in order to plate the
food the waitstaff are the bartender's
needed there their glasses and of course
the waitstaff needed the silverware so
you really had to be a team player and
that was really important so you learned
how to be part of a team that relied on
you to do your job correctly and of
course there's the idea of some rituals
and the rituals were also important you
had to empty the dish machine you know
every three hours and fill it up with
clean water you had to sweep the floor
at certain times throughout the night
you had them to the garbage at certain
specific times you had to do these
things so rituals played a big important
part of that and over the overarching
that was repetition you did it over and
over and over and over and over and over
again so you really got very good at it
and and when you translate that to what
a cook does it's basically the same
thing we have to be organized we have to
be efficient feedback is really really
important for us I mean one when we're
heating up oil in a saute pan to cook a
piece of fish and you put the fish in
there you know right away if the if the
pan was too hot if the pan wasn't hot
enough there's enough oil or doesn't
have enough oil right away you get the
feedback on how on how that ingredients
reacting in that pan and of course
rituals were important you have to do
things at specific times of the day to
get set up for service which begins at
5:30 and repetition I mean repetition
was such an integral part of becoming a
good cook you know learning how to slice
an onion you've all seen chefs on TV do
the onion thing really really quick and
you go how do they do that
we do it because we've done it 10,000
times
that's how we do it and you can do the
same thing it's not hard so when you
think about washing dishes it really set
the tone for me becoming a really good
cook interesting and then what was the
later experience that ultimately
convinced you that you wanted to commit
yourself to cooking well for the for the
first several years of cooking my mother
came to me one day I said you know the
chef is leaving you're gonna be the chef
and I thought wow this is interesting I
was a dishwasher yesterday and I'm gonna
watch this guy who's in this small
private Yacht Club in Palm Beach and I'm
gonna do what he does well fortunately I
have an older brother who who really
embraced cooking at a young age and he
was already a professional cook so he
became my first mentor but it wasn't
until 1977 when I met a French chef in
Narragansett Rhode Island where I was
working at a private club and and the
job that I had at that time was cooking
for the staff which was kind of a lowly
job right you weren't you weren't doing
the elegant food for the guests we were
paying you know high prices to come to
dinner I was cooking for the team there
and it's a summer job so you have all
these young people who are on summer
break and they're in Narragansett
because they can go to the beach in the
afternoon and they could work at night
and they have places to live and and and
so but the interesting about it was you
again the feedback feedback was really
important because when I would cook
something for them believe me they they
were very vocal about whether they liked
it or not right I mean there right away
this was good or this was bad and and
fortunately I was I was a pretty good
cook by then so most of the things I
made for them were really good and and
the chef came to me and he was very he
was very happy because typically his
staff cook wasn't somebody who had the
dedication of the skills that I have and
and the other staff was always unhappy
and and he made the connection for me on
why why cooks cook why any cook cooks
and it's it's to nurture people and and
when he said that to me I thought that
that's that's what I want to do that was
something that resonated with me the
idea that I could do something that
would nurture others and give them give
them not only sustenance but give them
pleasure was the reason I became a chef
so July 1977
I said this is my job this is what I'm
gonna do and from that point on I was
dedicated to really learning my craft my
craft and and it takes a long time you
know it wasn't until much later in life
so that was when I was you know 21 years
old and was wasn't until I was really 39
that I started to see any kind of
financial success or rewards from from
the work that I had been doing all those
years I like how often you're
referencing feedback because here at the
GSB we say that feedback is a gift it is
and all of us receive a lot of it so we
can certainly empathize with you it's a
good thing so that you moved on with no
formal training and that you didn't go
to culinary school and basically at
different jobs and apprenticeships
looking back and recognizing this
success that you've had how much of that
do you think is an 8 verse learned ah
good point I think that you know we look
at our early child life and I think that
we have a lot of things and certainly I
think all of you've got had gotten great
advice from your parents where somebody
that was meaningful for you because
you're all you're all here at Stanford I
mean you know you just don't show up
without having some guidance on that and
I think it early in my life again my my
parents are divorced so I grew up with
this with a single parent that was my
mother and I was very thankful that I
grew up with my mother because she had
an attention to detail a work ethic that
became part of who I was because she
exemplified that every day and it was
through those example those those
examples that again I find myself
looking back to and saying you know
there is the foundation of my success in
that early age of understanding what
what expectations were how to reach them
or how to exceed them in many ways and
and and the amount of dedication and
work that you had to contribute to
actually do that was was for me it was
it was a pleasure I would get excited by
it and to the point where I remember one
time and and and it was back when when
when people had
kind of fake foliage fake trees in their
house so my mother had this wonderful
kind of Japanese maple tree that was
plastic and I thought one day I'm gonna
take it apart I'm gonna really clean the
whole thing really good so I pulled the
whole thing apart and I cleaned every
leaf and every branch and I had it all
over the floor and and then I thought
back together again
she was happy that I cleaned it but she
was very upset that we weren't able to
put it back together again so often
times at school we discussed how to
respond to setbacks and the first
restaurant that you opened for Cal in
New York closed when the stock market
bottomed out in the end of the 1980s
what was the hardest part of that
experience for you I think the hardest
part of my experience is realized that
you're your ultimate dream and your
ultimate goal which was so so close and
in many ways what was in your grasp was
was something that could could just
disappear without without something that
you had no control over it
as hard as hard as you worked as
dedicated as you were as great a job as
you did at that point there was nothing
that I could do outside of changing the
format of the restaurant to to make
myself happier to make the restaurant
successful yeah so it was a choice and I
had a great partner service Raoul and he
had a very successful restaurant not too
far away across town in Soho and we had
the choice to either to to establish a
more of a casual restaurant because the
Strand yeah like a bistro was like this
was when you know fine dining became
something that was unapproachable
anymore people weren't willing to pay
for it and so everything was becoming
casual and so we could casual eyes the
Raquel I could stay there as partner and
as the chef or I could give it up and
pursue my goals and I was I was so
determined that fine dining was was
going to be my venue that I
I separated myself from the restaurant
that believe me I mean when we were
building the restaurant the contractors
would come in in the morning and they
would they would do their work and the
place would be a mess and every night I
would clean the restaurant knowing that
the contractors would come back the next
morning and make it a mess again I mean
there were nights I would sleep in the
restaurant this was this was this was my
life this was gonna be my restaurant
this was this was my future and and to
five years later realize that it wasn't
gonna be anymore in that New York City
which was which again was my life in the
center of the unit the universe for me
wasn't gonna wasn't gonna be the place
that I was gonna be was was devastating
but what are your choices I mean at the
end of the day you're faced with a
choice you know either
you can do something you can compromise
on what your goals are you know I could
have casualized the restaurant and been
there and been miserable or I could have
I could've left and pursued my two goals
of fine dining and and and hopefully
finding that that Avenue that would
leave me to to success and it that was
in 1990 when I when I when I left Raquel
and moved to Southern California and did
you take any lessons from that
experience maybe that would help you
fine dining big lessons big lessons I
knew that you know I realized that it
that I didn't know everything I mean you
know it's at some point in my life I
thought I knew everything I thought I
know how to run a restaurant but I
realized that I was a really good chef I
was a really good cook I no idea about
finances nothing I couldn't read a piano
and I didn't know how to run a dining
room and and those are a big part of a
restaurant you know certainly a big part
of any business and you know it turns a
financial so when I when I when I was
able to buy Raquel I was able to buy
French Laundry I realized that I needed
somebody in the dining room I can focus
on it there was an expert on the dining
room and I needed somebody you know who
could take care of our financial and so
it became a tripod there was me in the
kitchen focused on the food which was
really my expertise I realized that was
my expertise that was my strengths and I
need to play with my strengths and and
find those individuals who could
compensate for my weaknesses and so
Laura Cunningham became
the general manager the restaurant we
had a young bookkeeper named Pat
McCarthy and she took care of all of our
financials and that's what the basis and
the foundation was and it sounds like
you all kind of respected each other's
boundaries and well we were so busy that
there was there was no real choice yeah
you know we had to stay focused on our
different departments mm-hmm okay so
after 1994 when you opened the French
Laundry your presence on the culinary
scene just has exploded in terms of
opening up who Sean and Sean bakery per
se at hoc et cetera all of those
restaurants include different locations
different cuisine different clientele
what have been some of the driving
factors behind each decision to open a
new restaurant okay good good question I
just want to just if I can just yes they
way back to - to French Laundry because
you know it's something that's very
important for me to tell you is that as
we was pointed out it was 19 months I
was raising money for the French Laundry
now you know looking back at that time I
realized that my biggest asset was my
ignorance had I known what it was gonna
take to actually raise the money and buy
that restaurant when I began the process
it would have been overwhelming for me I
would have never done it what really
drove me forward and kept me motivated
were small successes every so often
I was in a position where I had closed
Raquel I was labeled you know someone
have an emotional chef which can be
interpreted in different ways
and and I had I was unemployed and
living in Los Angeles and I found this
restaurant and that I fell in love with
and I said there there's my my dream
there's where I should be there was an
instant connection for me and I decided
that I was gonna try to purchase the
restaurant but I had no resources I had
no money I had no job and it was really
through perseverance and through so many
other individuals around me that were
supportive of that process that we were
able to accomplish it but it was really
the unknown that protected me so well in
in in that in raising that money and
every day I would wake up and I would
make make phone calls or try to fill out
forms and and to think about that time
in my life and you know talking to over
400 people that I didn't know and asking
them for money I don't how many of you
have actually called people you don't
know and ask them to write you a check
it's it's it's a very difficult thing
but in the same time it reinforces Rhian
it reinforces your your ideals and
really what you want to do because you
say it over and over and over again
which are trying to accomplish and to
the point where if you didn't believe it
when you started you certainly believe
in yourself at some point along the road
and then to deal with with banks and and
I'm sure all of you dealt with banks
before but it's a very it's a very
difficult process is to try to get
people a bank to write you a cheque and
then the federal government on an SBA
loan a Small Business Administration
loan was also somewhat of a challenge
knowing that a white middle-class male
was applying for a small business loan
when they would give it to to to more or
less minorities was also a compliment so
the the ignorance factor would play a
very important part in my success
getting to your question about the the
different the different restaurants
around around the country and what drove
drove me to open more restaurants so in
the beginning it was it was always about
the French Laundry and and how to make
the French army better was always our
goal now our first restaurant we opened
was Bouchon which is just two blocks
south of the restaurant and the reason
we opened Bouchon was so that we can
have a place to eat I mean and honestly
I mean we there was a very small group
of individuals at the French shani where
we opened most of us came from urban
environments where we could go out after
work and get something to eat
whether it was in San Francisco LA or
New York we were used to that finishing
work at midnight and then going going
for dinner and in Napa Valley at that
time everything closed at 9:30 so what
do you do you
restaurant that stays open late and
fortunately had already guard garnered a
certain amount of respect and admiration
from from not only the press and from
the public but also from the partners
that we had so when I proposed opening a
French bistro in Yountville you know it
took me 18 months to raise 1.2 million
it took me 18 days to raise 1.5 million
so it just goes to show you success
breeds you know success and interest in
what you're doing and we opened Bhushan
but we opened Bhushan because it gave us
an opportunity to have a place to eat
now I knew at the same time that if my
little restaurant needed a place to go
to eat after work and Napa Valley being
a center for hospitality and what that
means is there's there are so many
restaurants in Napa Valley as well as
hotels everything is based on
hospitality so if we need a place to eat
then then they're obviously dozens of
others or hundreds of other people who
would love to have a place to eat as
well and so that was speculation but
obviously it paid off because the
restaurant stayed open to one o'clock in
the morning and it was packed every
night with with who with hospitality
workers the next thing we opened was
Bouchon Bakery and we opened Bouchon
Bakery because really again because of
the French Laundry and in Northern
California as you know we have probably
the the the the largest population of
the most amazing artists and bakers in
America we just do they all they all
travel in Northern California and so we
had we certainly had our pick of great
bread but none of them would bake bread
specifically - not necessarily the
standard we wanted but the size the
shape or the variety so what choice do
we have but to open our own bakery so we
opened a bakery to supply bread for the
French Laundry and obviously the
byproduct that would be supplied from
Bouchon and if you can open a bakery why
don't you open a little retail area so
people who come and and get morning
breakfast so we built a little a little
retail area and there's a little
courtyard there where today it is it's a
community center I mean it's a wonderful
thing to go down there in the morning
time and see people sitting around in
the morning having their coffee their
costs on and engaging with other people
you know it's really created this
this community of individuals whether
they're our neighbors whether they're
our friends or the visitors that come to
Napa Valley it's a wonderful experience
but I was really it was really the
genesis for French money so the first
expansion that I would really conceived
as expansion happened in 2004 is ten
years after we opened the French Laundry
I opened a restaurant in New York City
called per se and a restaurant in Las
Vegas called or a second Bouchon in Las
Vegas so that's where I really really
thought about expansion because it was
outside of that that a medium geography
the immediate geography of the French
Laundry or what what was right there
what I can control very easily because
they were right down the street and why
per se though well it's a very it's a
very you know it's a very easy question
to answer I mean if I asked that
question to all of you if you lived in
New York if you began your career in New
York if you've gotten some notoriety in
New York and you knew you had friends in
New York you knew the media in New York
and he had suppliers in New York where
would you go to open your next
restaurant you'd go to place where you
they knew you so going back to New York
for me was an obvious choice but but
also might you have to understand what
my life has been been very interesting
and I kind of separate myself from from
from from Thomas Keller many times I can
kind of look at it but when I moved to
California and I became became
successful you know at the French
Laundry
you know all my my my previous guests
you know and friends in New York said
when you coming home it's like coming
home what does that mean I was born in
California so when I came to California
in 1990
you know everybody thought I was coming
home to California so it can't this idea
of me being back and forth and you know
how LA and California have this kind of
a competitive edge with each other so
when I moved to California from New York
to California people thought California
so it's okay although I never really
lived in California when I when I got
the French on it as they said New Yorker
said when are you coming home so really
again gave me more confidence to go back
to New York because New Yorkers thought
I was from New York so per se was per se
me was born and it was a very
interesting process as well it was it
was a three and a half year project
which began in in mid-2000 and opened in
2004
and saw a lot of a lot of difficulty
obviously one of the big setbacks was
9/11 and and realizing that you know New
York had changed dramatically after
after that catastrophe and and and and
persevering through that process finally
opening the restaurant and then we had a
devastating fire in the restaurant which
closed the restaurant and it was a it
was a very as much as we had spent a lot
of time organizing the restaurant
designing the restaurant building the
restaurant staffing the restaurant we
closed the French Laundry this was this
was a business decision that I made late
in the process and and it was
interesting because I didn't think of it
and and you realize that that those
individuals that are around you and I
always listen to people and and I always
liked the idea of team and I like the
idea of a collaboration and many of the
ideas that I have aren't necessarily my
ideas there are other people's ideas and
I think one of the things that I'm able
to do is give others the confidence and
courage to express ideas I think we've
all been in those environments where
where we've we've been either prevented
or we're afraid to express our ideas to
to to our supervisors I try to give the
opportunity for anybody to say whatever
they want I don't want them to have an
impact and there was there was a woman
at the time when I was building per se
and that was with us that was actually
doing a her doctorate theses for the
other school in California we won't name
and and she spent two years with us
studying the the
business and at French Laundry and she
she actually published a book on it and
and she became a close friend and I
didn't know what I was gonna do when I
was opening per se as it relates to how
I was gonna open per se and maintain and
continue operate the French Laundry and
she got to know me so well we would sit
and talk and we were sitting in the
garden one day and she said Thomas you
know I know you've been struggling with
this but it's very obvious to me what
you should do I said Rebecca what is
that she said just close the French
Laundry
I thought wow what an idea just close
the French Laundry now from a business
point of view you're gonna close a
restaurant that's doing you know over a
million dollars a month in business
you're gonna close it for five months to
go open another restaurant which has
nothing to do with the partners of the
original restaurant right so you're a
partner of the French ROM you go wait a
minute why would you why why would you
do that well we're gonna do that for a
number of different reasons we're gonna
do that because if we do this
successfully in New York City it's gonna
have a very positive impact on the
French Laundry it's going to give us the
opportunity to really have this this
cultural exchange between two
restaurants that has never been done
before so we did that we closed the
French Laundry
we moved 30 individuals like Noah's Ark
we moved 30 staff members from the
French Laundry from different
departments that were intended to go to
New York temporarily to help inoculate
this team in New York and then they'd
come back and up with the French Laundry
and that's exactly what we did and and
to this day it established such a strong
foundation for for that restaurant that
almost immediately it became one of the
best restaurants in New York City and
ultimately one of considered one of the
best restaurants in the country
now you could argue a lot of different
things we could we've done that before
without that well there's this idea
certainly in the media as it relates to
chefs that we spread ourselves too thin
has anybody heard that expression Oh
actually I've sprayed himself too thin I
know he's opening another restaurant
that's not a good thing for him to do
they don't say that but any other
businesses do they I mean Hermes can
open as many shops as they want without
somebody saying what Hermes are
spreading himself too thin right I mean
you think about you think about retail
you think about general commerce and
most people think well you should just
continue to grow but when it comes to
restaurants and chefs mm-hmm it's a bad
thing and I tried to explain is that
that is such I'm trying to it's it's
it's it's so wrong when you think about
you could have said what you have so
it's Oh hon sorry it's so wrong because
when you think about it if I have the
French Laundry where there's a hundred
employees is understaffed numbers right
they're all focused they have a common
vision we have common goals we're
achieving great expectations we're
exceeding our standards we're doing all
the things right we open per se and I've
got 150 employees there who doing the
same thing so now I have 250 people that
are working for me that are all folks
how am I have I become weaker how I
stretched myself too thin I mean we've
become that much stronger by opening
another restaurant so really it really
you know this idea that you know there I
I must admit that some of my colleagues
may be doing doing things other ways
that don't really enhance or strengthen
their their businesses but if you do it
correctly if you really think about you
do it for the right reasons
I mean you we become so much stronger we
were able to exchange you know I've
always worked towards this exchange
program we've always continue to
exchange staff the last summer we
exchanged our chef de cuisine 'he's
right the heads of the kitchens from the
french auntie and per se they got in
airplanes at the same time went to each
other's restaurants right for 15 days
they walked into each other's
restaurants and operated each other's
restaurants without a problem
now we built up to that because as Eli
came to Yountville he was walking to
restaurant where Matthew was now Matthew
had worked for Eli in New York and came
to to Yountville right so he's walking
into an area where Mike Wallace was
there
Mike Wallace work for free Lyon in New
York Timothy was walking into restaurant
where Nick was there who had worked for
Timothy in Yountville so we have this
wonderful exchange program where we
built this the this culture of knowledge
and the ability for if you're a young
chef you can come to French Laundry and
work in this beautiful idea like Napa
Valley and when you get tired of that
you know we'll send you off to New York
City this vibrant exciting you know
place in New York and you can go go to
work there so this idea of this exchange
that we have has created a bond a bond
between the restaurants that is that
that exchanges knowledge so you think
about evolution we all talk about
evolution well we have a rapid rate of
evolution because now no longer do we
have just a hundred people thinking
about something we have 250 people
thinking about something so our
evolution is it just goes out such a
pace it's hard to keep up sometimes with
what's going on in our restaurants
because there are everybody is
exchanging ideas and then we become
strong we've got the strength of our
restaurants is is extraordinary when I
look at when I look at this and and I've
said you know it's almost like a I write
up I run a sports franchises the way I
describe it because we have to be
thinking generation generationally about
who is coming up who's going to be
replacing who and how we're gonna do
that how we're meant to how we're hiring
how we're mentoring how we're training
our staff so that they can become sooner
or later can become the franchise player
and and ultimately then let them go and
become become their own business you
know that's that's the ultimate goal is
to actually push them out so that they
can start their own restaurants and be
successful on their own so at the
beginning of what you're just describing
the hiring piece yes what are the top
three qualities that you look for when
hiring new talent for one of your
restaurants desire desire and desire you
were quoted saying that it's desire that
really matters it's not passion leading
people talk about passion you know I
sometimes it drives me crazy you know
some of the some of the vocabulary that
we use in people's house a young coconut
a say so why do you want to work your
chef I'm so passionate about what I do
you don't believe the passion I have I
mean every morning I wake up I'm so
passionate about this I'm thinking okay
whatever this kid just doesn't doesn't
understand it's wonderful to think it
like that right think that you're gonna
be passionate about your job all the
time
but we all know I mean passion absent
flows I mean if you've ever had a
relationship with somebody I mean I mean
they're there in lies the perfect
example of you know how how passion goes
I mean we're passionate about somebody
you know for a while then it kind of
subsides and then you know reignites for
some reason you know it's all over the
place right and and if you relate that
to food I mean you know the the first
asparagus of the spring which we saw
three weeks ago you just like wow it's
amazing you haven't seen it all year
long it's like I love it you know I'm
passionate about doing something with
asparagus but what happens three weeks
later when you've seen asparagus every
for the past three weeks it's like okay
or whatever you know it's just another
bundle of asparagus I got to do
something so what keeps you going with
is it's the desire it's a desire to do
something with the asparagus it's the
desire to be with that person that keeps
you with that person because it was all
based on passion we'd have a different
partner every other year right it's the
desire to do something that really
drives us so that's what I look for is I
look for that desire I know that there
are levels of skill that some people are
born with and some people will be stars
and some people won't
and and it breaks my heart to see those
young individuals that are in our
restaurants whether they're in the
kitchen in the dining room who have this
strong desire to do a good job and they
just don't have the skills to do it that
that's really heartbreaking and we try
to find places for them where they're
gonna succeed maybe it's not at the
French Laundry
maybe it's at Bouchon maybe it's at a
colleague's restaurant and then and then
there's those ones who have amazing
skill and you know they could be a star
but you know they just they just don't
have the desire and and that breaks your
heart because you just want to stop them
in the face you know you are so good how
come you don't you apply yourself more
it's about desire is there a question
you asked in interviews to tease out
whether someone has no really you know
it's what we what we the way we
interview is we have them in our kitchen
you know if we're talking about a
culinary person we want them to come
into our kitchen for two different
reasons we want to watch the way they
move it's it's a dance you know I mean
let's face it in the kitchen that is
that is crowded with people and you know
everybody's moving it you know it
intense speeds everybody's focused it's
it's about how you move in the kitchen
so we want to really see how they're
moving in and sometimes it's an innate
thing as well understanding who's behind
you how you feel about about being close
with people cuz we touch every you know
it's it's like a basketball game you're
right you're constantly touching
somebody you know and if if people don't
like to be touched that's a problem but
making but having them in the kitchen
gives us two opportunities gives us an
opportunity to see how they move through
the kitchen to see how they react to
others in the kitchen and you know to
give them some basic skills you know
here here yours here's an egg scramble
an egg or you know here's some
vegetables chop an onion or things like
that
we can out we can teach almost anything
if some
he has a strong desire to do it but the
other important thing during that aspect
is for them to actually see the kitchen
themselves and we want them to answer
the question do I think I can work in
that environment mm-hmm so I know what
they're getting themselves exactly and
and and you'd be surprised how many
people realize that they can't work in
that environment it's too intense it's
too quick it's too difficult it requires
too much dedication the hours are too
long I mean all these different things
that come into into effect you can look
at somebody's resume they come out of
school they're there they're recommended
by by somebody and and yes I mean you
you know it's it's it's a gamble you
know you flip a coin we've had we've had
very successful chefs who come from
I mean Timothy Hollingsworth who came
from from basically nowhere 13 years ago
began working the French on tea and
became the chef de cuisine without any
any formal education as well his whole
education was at the French Laundry as a
young he came at 21 years old he just he
left last week he came in as a Comey
which is the lowest level position in
the kitchen and he left the highest
level of the position with you know with
the respect of an industry competed as
the buku store captain who placed higher
for the US than any other team had ever
done and his only experience in the
kitchen was that the French Laundry and
he got there by accident because my chef
who was in at the time Eric Z bald
didn't want to hire him and and I didn't
I didn't realize that he didn't want to
hire him so I hired him and he gets in
the kitchen and and so you just never
know but but you have this you you have
other people who have great resumes who
come from great houses and and and they
just they fall they they fail so it's
it's hard to really tell it's it's a
it's an important process of hiring we
we have to spend our time making sure
that we're trying to identify the right
person for the right job I mean that's
an important thing and back when I was
young in in the business it was about
being in the right place at the right
time you know if you were there when
they needed somebody you were hired
doesn't necessarily mean that you were
good at what you did or that you had a
great background you were just the right
place at the right time and and and they
would beat you in a submission or
Beaches the point where you you
became you understood what they wanted
and you did it that the beating was
always there but today we want to make
sure that we're hiring the right person
for the right job
and putting him in a position where we
can we can train them because that
that's really an important part is
training and again training has no time
limits when you think about it I mean
you're native to a child and I don't
know how many you have children but when
you're teaching your child how to swim
you've got floaties on their arms you
don't tell them they have two weeks that
are not a swim and then you can take the
floaties off think it drowns well it's
your fault you know you didn't learn how
to swim in two weeks I mean it could
take it could take two months we could
take three months the point is once you
hire a person you have to be committed
to that person hundred percent and that
training can take a while and and but
the commitment has to be there and the
commitment from them has to be there and
and the deciding factor and that is when
they have a hard day and you go to them
and say Walter you know you struggled
today what do you think about tomorrow
and the kids got a smile on faces Jeff
I'm gonna get it tomorrow I'll be back
tomorrow and and and and that stro it
shows a strong dedication strong will
and an attitude that they know in their
mind that one day they'll get it if you
have the patience and persistence to
continue working with them they'll get
it one day
and believe me when they get it it's an
extraordinary thing to watch because
it's like turning a light on one day
they'll come in and it's just it's like
night and day and then that person that
you've spent the time with that you've
dedicated that training moment you've
given him what he needs or she needs you
know Walter was with us for four six and
a half years an extraordinary young chef
to today now is a chef too was inna in
another restaurant and then and then the
point is so if you hired you trained and
then you have to mentor them and
mentorship is something that goes beyond
beyond work you know it's it's it's a
it's a process it's a life process and
the point is if you fired correctly if
you train correctly and you mentored
correctly then the result of that is
it's that you have somebody who is
better than you are and and that was
that's a hard thing for a lot of chefs
to say is that person is better than I
am but if they're not then you really
haven't done your job very well have you
I mean they have to be better than you
are you have to give them a better
environment you have to give them better
skills you have to give them better
to work with you have to give them a
better education you have to give them a
better opportunity than you ever had and
if you do all those things then then the
the overarching goal that we talked
about is raising the the standards of
our profession have been achieved I know
that there are some fantastic questions
in the audience so I do want to open up
for questions from the audience if you
have a question please raise your hand
and someone with the microphone will
find you my question is about you you've
been quoted to to speak about the
importance of ownership in every person
in the restaurant and you've said that
you don't work for somebody your whole
life and then suddenly wake up one
morning and think like an owner right
could you talk about what you've done to
instill that in people at your
restaurant given that it is a high
turnover industry yeah yeah it's funny
because we don't really have a high
turnover as much as you know it is a
high turnover industry our turnover
really occurs when when there's not the
ability for somebody to be promoted and
that's typically because you know as
it's a pyramid and as you get up towards
the top those individuals are staying
longer so you know as a Comey goes to a
chef to party chef the party goes to
Demi's sous-chef that my sous chef goes
to sous chef sous chef goes to executive
sous-chef and then goes the CDC there
are fewer fewer people so typically
somebody leave after two or
two-and-a-half years at the chef de
Partie level but to answer your question
we've preparing them to be a chef to
Azim we're preparing them to be a chef
to cuisine because we begin them as a
Khomeni so at that level at that
beginning level they're understanding
the foundation of the kitchen really
understand the true foundation of how to
operate a kitchen opening kitchen what
what what the what the fundamental
practices are how to do how to do the
fundamental work and and at the same
time they get to work with a chef to
party a chef to party is somebody who
actually is responsible for a station
you know fish meat vegetable cheese
whatever the different stations are in
the restaurant so you've created this
this team environment and the chef de
Partie is now working with that with
that Co me or that group of homies and
and and and supervising them managing
them in a way that they are actually
understanding what it is to be a chef
because now they have their own little
small team that they divide we define
the menu
stay to find their dishes and then they
start to write out their list of tasks
they have to be done and they have to
then then motivate supervise their
commis in order to get the the task
completed in the appropriate amount of
time so as a chef de Partie you're
learning you and a couple of it as a
Comey your next position would be a chef
to party so you're learning as a Comey
what it's like to be managed by somebody
at that fount of that Foundation and
then you're promoted to the chef de
Partie positions so that the roles are
reversed you understand what you need to
do in those positions so as a chef de
Partie you understand how to manage and
supervise that position so we're
teaching them how to be chefs little
mini chefs in their stations before
they're ever become a sous chef if you
forget you get to become a sous chef
then you're now responsible for a group
of chef's to parties that for all the
chef's to parties before group to chef
to parties so you're managing or
supervising even even more people if you
get to be an executive sous-chef the
executive sous-chef is the same as a
chef de cuisine in other words he's
responsible for the entire kitchen and
understanding how to supervise and
manage that group and then as a chef de
cuisine obviously you're responsible for
the entire kitchen now start to revert
to what what it is to operate a business
it's not just about the kitchen I mean
the kitchen is a very important part of
any restaurant but it's it's not it's it
it's not the area where you're going to
find success in being a business owner
and and that was evident as I spoke
earlier me being a really good chef
didn't make didn't qualify me to run a
business in fact it qualified me to run
a business into the ground and be
unsuccessful so so understanding that
you know at that point when to become
the executive chef even when they become
a sous chef they start to understand
human resources they start to understand
public relations they start to
understand the finances so that they can
start and start to formulate what it is
that they are impacting so as they're as
they begin to order food they understand
you know how to keep inventories how to
price inventories they understand how to
not how to manage inventories and then
the more the further up they go as an
executive sous chef and as executive
sous chef and chef de cuisine now are in
the budgetary process so every year they
are actually right
their budgets for for for their
department so we're actually teaching
them how to be these owners before their
owners and that's that's really what I
want to be able to do and and then as
they start to understand that they're
working in human resources and public
relations as well so they have really
the three criterias that they need in
order to understand how to open their
own restaurant and then and then
understanding that there's a
transitional period I know if I walk
into my kitchen today and I said who
wants to open their own restaurant 95%
of us hands are going to go up so
annoying immediately that everybody in
my restaurant is in my kitchen is gonna
leave some day prepares me for these
transitions so understanding that as a
chef to asine that that chef wants to
open his own restaurant so we begin
early in the process so that we have a
smooth transition process for him to be
able to not only learn what he needs to
learn about running a restaurant but now
how to open a restaurant so we can offer
that person the only the financial
information needs but but also legal to
help him understand how to write a
business plan and preparing him for that
so the ownership is it becomes something
that is very tangible for them at a very
early age in their career at our
restaurants because they are owning it
even though they may not realize it so
that when someone leaves our restaurant
even now to even have a young age even
at a young position at a shefte party's
position damn they've already tasted and
felt what it's like to be a chef hi my
name is Candace Cromartie I'm a first
year MBA I was just curious what right
now your favorite thing to cook is my
right now we have some beautiful white
asparagus that's right right now I know
it's interesting we were talking about
this a little earlier about you know
about ingredients and now and I mean
they are the most important part of what
we do and and and the seasonality of
them we realize that the proteins are
very easy right I mean we forecast our
proteins every week we
we don't necessarily forecast our
vegetables every week we know that you
know our duck producer is gonna produce
ducks for us every week we know our lamb
roars got lamb we know or you know our
ranch in Idaho has beef for us we know
you know that the fish we're gonna get
you know we know we'll mostly we know
what we're gonna get if we can't get Cod
this week we'll get another fish but we
know we can get these different proteins
it's really it really we really build
our menus around the vegetables because
vegetables have a defined season we all
think of seasons seasonality as you know
spring summer winter fall but that that
has nothing to do with the seasonality
that we deal with because the fava bean
for us may only have a season of three
and a half or four weeks we may see fava
beans in the market for three and a half
months but we know that the last two and
a half months those fava beans you know
typically are overgrown and starchy and
we don't really want to work with that
so really understanding the seasonality
of each ingredient and certainly in this
aspect as relates to vegetables so right
now you know the white asparagus that
we're getting the white asparagus we're
getting right now is from is from
Germany which which arguably has some of
the best white asparagus that's
available because they have they they're
the northern north of Germany you think
of the Scandinavian countries they have
white asparagus as well but it's still a
little too cold so they don't get as as
median as big and then further south in
France it's already getting too warm by
the time their season hits Jeremy has
that wonderful wonderful season that
prime season when the temperatures are
just right for the growing of asparagus
and the size that we like and the
texture that we like so I hope that
answered your question but they won't be
around much longer
I thanks for coming here it's really
excited to have you to jump off on that
question could you talk a little bit
about your supply chain there's a lot of
it coming from local organic farms or is
it sort of worldwide I'm glad you asked
that question you know people talk about
there's all this this talk recently
about local right everybody has anybody
heard not heard that you know local is a
but I've heard the word sustainability
in the in the past three or four years
you know chefs have always been focused
on on quality ingredients you know and
chefs have always been focused on our
farmers our suppliers so this whole idea
that farm-to-table of something new is a
bit absurd and insulting to me you know
because you know it's something that
we've every chef in every generation any
chef that's that that's been worth
anything has always been had
relationships with with their farmers
their fishermen their foragers their
gardeners I mean those those individuals
are who we rely on I mean we truly
support them in what they do in every
way and and local has nothing to do with
geography I mean where did where did
this idea come from that we have to use
products within 25 miles and what is
wood but what defines local anyway is
local
you look at the dig what is local can
anybody define it for me I was I was I
was doing a lecture couple weeks ago and
someone was that was 25 miles okay so
it's 25 miles right so that means if
this farmer is growing a carrot within
25 miles I can buy it and if it's a
shitty carrot that's okay
it's local but if there's the guy 27
miles away that's growing the most
amazing carrot that you've ever tasted I
can't buy that carrot and by the way
what are you drinking coffee is there is
is there a coffee plantation 25 miles
from here you know like what's that
about I mean we have it we you know we
live with a little bit of hypocrisy all
of us do so if we believe we're truly
buying a local ingredients but we're
drinking tea or coffee or sugar or using
vanilla or oil or you know any of these
things I mean you tell me you tell me
where where these farms are where these
producers are that are producing all
these things locally you know and what
is local anyway is that 25 is it 50 is
the hundreds of 200 to 300 miles you
know around I have no idea what that
local with local means so local to me
has to do with ingredients we realized
that the culinary diversity of the world
has been based on transportation right
do we agree on that
I mean the most famous country in the
world for chocolate is where
Switzerland do they have any cocoa
plantations and switch them I don't
think so
the Italians are known for what tomatoes
tomatoes came from the new world right
they didn't come from Italy
the Italians Evert potatoes the Irish
potato famine in the 1600s right they
got the potatoes from from from Peru I
mean it wasn't something that they had
locally it was brought there by by by
somebody from a bone so the the spice
roots you know of ancient times I mean
this is this has been the makeup of our
culinary heritage for centuries for and
it's not going to stop so why would we
say we're not going to support any
longer the the the the the the the the
coffee bean plantations in in South
America or Sumatra or we're not going to
we're not going to support the the
vanilla bean plantations in Mexico or
Tahiti I mean would we really do that
would we put out would we put out of
business these communities that have
been thriving for decades or centuries
on the idea of exporting their food and
then how many of you drink wine and is
anybody drink French wine would you
think that comes from local I you know
all these different things it's just
fascinates me that local has been has
has been defined as something that is
within a certain proximity locals about
the ingredients and the quality of the
ingredients to me that's what it's all
about
it's about communities that are
producing food for us and we talk about
sustainability the sustainability has
nothing to do with ingredients they're
saying ability has to do with
communities communities are very
important so if I'm buying my
ingredients from the right individuals
there they're the ones that are going to
be concerned about the sustainability of
their ingredients i buy lobsters from
Ingrid Ben gist who lives in Stonington
Maine is anyone we're starting to menas
has anybody been to starting today there
you go if if that community of fishermen
had to rely on selling their fish in
their lobsters within a certain
proximity to that town that community
would not exist there would not be the
the fisherman there that it would not be
the teachers there or the doctors there
are the pharmacists there there would
not be a community in Stoney
in Maine if they couldn't transport
their local ingredients elsewhere and
then they're worried about the
sustainability this is a community
that's been there for generations
they're the ones that that that are that
are monitoring the quality of their
harvesting of the lobsters or the
scallops because every year for 30 years
I've been buying lobsters and scallops
and Cod things from from Ingrid benches
okay and she buys them from her
fishermen so there's a sustainability in
the community and those fisherman's are
the ones that are worried about the
sustainability of what they're
harvesting so I shouldn't really have to
worry about the sustainability of those
ingredients or or the locality of them
other than we're supporting people who
are who are doing who are doing work
that had been going out for generations
and supporting a community around them I
answer your question organic I'm sorry
organic is that doesn't matter it
doesn't matter to me because again we
buy ingredients for for therefore the
flavor for the quality of the ingredient
and and and sometimes our ingredients
that aren't organic are much better than
something that's labeled organic and if
I'm gonna tell my my farmer in
Yountville
that he has to get certified organic
from the state of California so he's for
five years he's gonna have to monitor
his I have to send in every six months
or every three months his test results
would cost him money he's gonna have to
wait for the state to verify that and
then and then give him a stamp on a
piece of paper that says he's organic
when he's been when he's been farming
this his father farm the farm and his
grandfather farm the farmer they've
always been practicing organic you know
what he's gonna tell me right it's gonna
tell me to stick it because you know he
doesn't need to be involved in the
bureaucracy of the state certifying his
property Organic when he's been farming
organic for four generations
sorry no it's clear you've thought a lot
about the topic
so I want to close with a question
that's asked at many of you from the top
engagements the current GSP application
includes an essay that asks what matters
most to you and why how would you
respond to that question
you know I think what matters most to me
now is really education I think
education is is is the tool for success
in anything we do in life and you know
our profession was one that we were told
how to do something for so long and not
necessary why and you know it's only
been recently in in my career span in
the past 25 years that we've actually
learned why we bet actually become more
knowledgeable on on the science of food
right you've all seen a lot of things
that Harold McGee wrote a book 30 years
ago called you know on food and cooking
which really opened up so much knowledge
for for so many cooks who never
understood you know why in a
multiplication worked you know what was
it what was the property and the fat of
an egg yolk in the oil that brought it
together and how much could you do and
and and it was the knowledge that opened
up a lot of doors for us and and I would
say that what we want to be able to do
to do is is is to share that knowledge
with everybody to to help impact and
enrich people's lives and and certainly
in my profession it's it's been an
extraordinary rise in in knowledge and
an understanding of what we do and why
we do it that in America today we live
with the culinary culture today that is
only 30 years old and we have achieved
enormous success notoriety and and
reputation because of the knowledge that
we have and the dedication we have to
our craft and to each other I think
those are important things thanks for
sharing so before we finish I understand
that you have a surprise for people in
the audience we do there's a story about
green green tapes has anybody heard the
green tape story no one person heard the
green tape story so you know as I told
you when we were opening per se we took
30 individuals from French on E 2 per se
to help inoculate this this group of
people in
at in New York City with our culture in
our philosophy and so I gave them all
this this you know this big rah-rah
speech about you know you're gonna go
there you're gonna meet people it's New
York City we want to make sure that we
teach you know this new staff who we are
give them the examples of who we are
find something find a way to to just
make it better a little bit you know
find something that's gonna impact them
find something that's gonna say
something to these individuals in New
York and we had a young expediter named
Zion qu al I think he's probably 23 24
years old at the time who worked at The
French Laundry now the green tape was
something that we use at our restaurant
I began using 1994 it's painters tape
right and and and we use it to label
everything in the restaurant and the
reason we use green tape is because
masking tape which is typically used or
labels which are typically used have
such a strong adhesive that when you
take them off it leaves a residue on the
container I hated that I do know it just
drove me crazy green tape has a very
light adhesive so then when you take it
off nothing stays on the container so
every container everything that's marked
at the restaurant is marked with green
tape every time we tape down the past
which means we put a tablecloth on the
past the table that we played our food
on it's taped down with green tape for
10 years an entire decade hundreds of
people toward the green tape right we
would just tear it Grant Achatz
Jonathan bento Sebastian Bach cell Eric
Z bald I mean dozens of chefs today does
is the people in our profession today
Paul Roberts sommelier I mean you know
man everybody nobody thought about doing
anything else but tearing the green tape
Zion who L who taped on the past at the
French chandi every day for two years
shows up in New York City on February 16
2004 the first day he's taping down the
past for the first service of per se
what does he do it picks up a pair of
scissors and cuts the green tape
everybody in the entire restaurant was
like what
what just happened and and from that
moment on 600 other employees where
there's a roll of green tape there's a
pair of scissors and it just goes to
show you how big of an impact one person
can have just with the idea that they're
gonna make a difference and it wasn't a
big thing you know it wasn't it wasn't
sudden when you think about it's like
okay whatever he picked up a pair of
scissors to cut the green tapes that's
it's not such a stretch is it but he did
it he thought about it he made an impact
he had the confidence and he had the
courage to pick up a pair of scissors
and cut the green tape and now I have
over a thousand people that work at TK
RG and everywhere there's a roll of
green tape there's a pair of scissors
and now they have actually dispensers so
they don't have to be there I don't know
where the dispenser came from but
somebody thought about the dispenser so
with that said there is three pieces
I hope it's cut green tape thank you
there's three pieces of green tape under
your chair okay so there are three
chairs with a piece of green tape under
it and we want to be able to give you
something from us so whoever has a piece
of green tape let me know
do you remember where you put them
anybody find green to any fine green
tape oh we've got one where right here
and back there where's the third you
have three okay come on
thank you everybody I appreciate it
you
[Music]